>> Bret: WHEN YOU READ IT
REALLY SLOWLY YOU’RE IN AT THE
TOP OF THE HOUR.
GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON I’M BRET BAIER AND
KIND OF WRONG FOURTH OF JULY
FIREWORKS FLEW ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FOR OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
100 SHOTS AND DOZENS KILLED.
CHICAGO PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS
AND TWO CHILDREN KILLED THERE.
GEORGIA, ALSO, THE GOVERNOR HAS
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
CALLING IN THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
PROTECT CITIZENS AFTER THE
SHOOTING DEATH OF AN 8-YEAR-OLD
GIRL.
IT ALL COMES AMID A SERIOUS
SITUATION OVER THE WEEKEND IN
WHICH THE SHOOTINGS, THE
GOVERNOR DECLARING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT CITIZENS
AFTER THE SHOOTING OF AN
8-YEAR-OLD GIRL IN GEORGIA.
IT IS COMING AS WE HAVE FOX TEAM
COVERAGE TONIGHT.
A BRIT HUME WITH THE
DIVISIVENESS BETWEEN THE LEFT
AND RIGHT ON THIS WEEKEND AND
WHAT’S HEARD OVER THE WEEKEND.
KRISTIN FISHER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE PRESIDENT’S
COMMENT ABOUT THE VIOLENCE AND
WE START OFF WITH CORRESPONDENT
MATT FINN AND THE SITUATION IN
CHICAGO.
MATT.
>> GEORGIA STUCK GOVERNOR DEPLOY
TROOPS TO PROTECT STATE
BUILDINGS AND THE GOVERNOR’S
MANSION AND THE GOVERNOR SINK
THEY’LL ALLOW LONG LOCK IN FOR
CEMENT.
ONCE AGAIN COME UP PLAGUING THE
CITY OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> TO SEE MY DAUGHTER ON THE
TABLE WITH A GUNSHOT WOUND TO
THE POOR HAD COME IN.
>> SEVEN YEAR OLD WALLACE WAS
KILLED OVER THE WEEKEND IN
CHICAGO AND SHE PLAYED OUTSIDE
WITH HER SIBLINGS.
>> VISUALIZE THE SEVEN-YEAR-OLD
CHILD LEADING TO DEATH IN THE
FAMILY IS THERE.
>> AMONGST THE INNOCENT VICTIMS
COME UP PEOPLE’S A 14-YEAR-OLD
JONES WAS SHOT AND KILLED BY
GANG MEMBERS ON THE
FOURTH OF JULY.
>> IF BLACK LIVES DON’T MATTER
TO US, HOW THE HECK IS IT GOING
TO MATTER TO ANYBODY ELSE?
>> CHICAGO POLICE A NEARLY 90
PEOPLE WERE SHOT SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE LONG WEEKEND ON
THURSDAY.
17 PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
EVEN THOUGH 1200 ADDITIONAL
OFFICERS WERE ADDED TO THE
STREETS FOR THE HOLIDAY.
TODAY, CHICAGO’S POLICE
SUPERINTENDENT DAVID BROWN SAYS
THERE’S HOPEFULLY NO CONSEQUENT
AS FOR LEGAL COMPOSITION IN
CHICAGO.
HE’S DEPENDING STRICTER
SENTENCES AND CRITICIZING THE
DECISION-MAKERS WHO HE SAYS ARE
RELEASING REPEAT VIOLENT
OFFENDERS.
>> MANY OF THE PEOPLE COME RIGHT
BACK TO THE VERY COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY COMMITTED THEIR
CRIMES.
TO COMMIT MORE CRIMES.
>> NEW YORK, AT LEAST EIGHT
PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND 44 SHOT
OVER THE WEEKEND AFTER WHAT WAS
REPORTEDLY THE CITIES BLOODIEST
YOU AND IN 24 YEARS.
NYPD FORMER COMMISSIONER IS
BLASTING MAYOR BILL de BLASIO
CALLING HIM "ATROCIOUS" FOR
LIMITING THE ANTI-CRIME UNIT IN
CITIES WHO CUT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> ANOTHER 18 MONTHS, IT’S VERY
DISCOURAGING.
>> EVEN ATLANTA, 24 PEOPLE WERE
SHOT SATURDAY NIGHT INTO SUNDAY.
THREE OF THE PEOPLE DIED
INCLUDING THE 8-YEAR-OLD GIRL,
WHEN SOMEONE OPENED FIRED ON HER
MOTHER’S CAR.
>> YOU CAN’T BLAME THIS ON THE
POLICE OFFICER, YOU CAN’T SAY
THAT THIS IS ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
CARRYING SOME WEAPONS WHO SHOT
UP A CAR WITH A EIGHT YEAR OLD
BABY IN THE CAR.
FOR WHAT?
>> NEW YORK MARIBEL
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO